hi I'm Erik Bosse and Aquaman released
an extended look that's really so much
more than just a trailer it's really
like a five minute Chilean sea bass
serving the footage really it's just a
clip that was actually shown to
comic-con fans last summer so for me
being left at work alone that weekend is
actually paying off let's dive in and
run through all the new Easter eggs and
visual details that you might have
missed in this footage its spoiler
warning in case I end up revealing too
much okay the first interesting detail
comes right away with this opening shot
of a snow globe containing the amnesty
Maine lighthouse at Thomas curry lives
in but look underneath that snow globe
this book is the Dunwich horror by HP
Lovecraft
Lovecraft is known for his cosmic horror
imagery depictions of unfathomable
Terror looming over us just beyond the
abyss James Wan has mentioned Lovecraft
as a major influence on his visual style
and some of the visuals that we've seen
and this Aquaman footages certainly
Lovecraftian in nature
now the Dunwich horror as a book doesn't
so much deal with the oceanic abyss but
it does center around two brothers two
brothers who are part of two worlds not
too different from these half-brothers
Arthur and orme
one of whom belongs to two worlds and
moving on past Thomas and atlanna nicole
kidman spooning we see a more complete
cut of Arthur lifting a submarine to the
surface and boarding it now I'm assuming
this is a sub of black mantas father
whom I don't think will survive this
battle and maybe that is what turns
Black Manta against Aquaman then after
some cool-looking aerial shots of the
Warner Brothers and DC logos submerged
in shallow waters we move on to this
extended scene of Arthur and mera
exploring the Sahara Desert in search of
these Atlantean ruins yes it is a little
odd that this ancient kingdom known for
its water connection is located in this
modern-day African and arid desert but I
think that's the idea right in ancient
times before the plates of the Earth's
crust shifted the Sahara was actually
more lush and green in the body of water
that is now the Mediterranean Sea
covered a lot more land so this said
Landis capital could have been left in
what is now the Sahara Desert millions
of years after the Seas scaled back and
dried out the land and by the way that
would make the Atlanteans truly ancient
like they would have had to have existed
millions of years before Homo sapiens
even began to evolve or depending on
your views were placed here look just
don't ask me how Thomas Curie was able
to mate with one of these freaky
prehistoric water he
anyway Mira and Arthur explored these
badass ruins plugging in this ancient
Amazon echo to hear a Princess Leia
style hollow recording from King at land
played by actor graham mctavish
now Mira has the powers of hydro Kinesis
which she uses to absorb water from
Arthur's sweat and splash it on to the
device to activate it the production
design here definitely appears to be
influenced by the movie the pith element
which features similar ancient stone
Amazon echoes one of which needs actual
water to activate so they use drops of
sweat in this case Arthur suggests a
different source of water could've just
peed on it
good for you Aquaman keeping up with the
pee jokes of the DC EU after Lex Luthor
suggested serving a dura piss to a u.s.
senator during that lands away message
we hear this interesting a decent score
that reminds me a lot of these stranger
things need
[Music]
and there's some new dazzling shots of
Atlantis underwater with their giant sea
turtle convoys and a quick shot of at
lands Trident being forged from molten
gold the imagery here reminds me a lot
of the forge scene in Game of Thrones
remember when Tywin Lannister melted
down Ned Stark's sword ice to form the
two Valyrian steel swords widows wail
and Oathkeeper and the way that Game of
Thrones is a royal drama about a bastard
revealed as a true heir to an ancient
throne it looks like Aquaman will follow
in those steps we also see the ancient
Atlantis in its heyday and it's pretty
legit now there's a ton of details that
I want to get into but first thanks for
a response Irvin Sara watches now look I
wasn't always a guy who cared about what
was on my wrist Elissa was a comic-con
wristband just kidding I had to work but
since you folks got a look at me it
doesn't hurt to class it up sometimes
and you would be amazed how much this
watch from vince arrow just completes
your look and really elevates your game
it's just so classy and well crafted
with nice finishing attention to detail
and guys it's still super affordable
plus it's not that minimalist
cookie-cutter design that some other
dopes wear with this you just stand out
you get noticed and no one's gonna bully
you on that field trip to the aquarium
when you got a bold icy face blue back
Kyros with crocodile finish on that
black leather band but Sarah apparently
just received their twelve thousand five
star review on their site a lot of
people are like in their luxurious style
check out their site first up for their
variety of designs and colors it's a
good fit for anyone who wants to look
their best and we're doing a special
offer just for you guys click on the
link below and use the discount code
rock stars we're 15% off your entire
order ok back to this Aquaman footage of
the ancient Atlantis city I just love
the way the production design takes
inspiration from plastic Greek and Roman
architecture against the aqueducts and a
forum esque thoroughfare you can even
see a Coliseum in the corner there but
then this shockwave blast implies that
the original tried it may have fallen
into the wrong hands is the kind of
weapon of mass destruction leading to
the original Kingdom collapsing and
breaking into the Seven Kingdoms there's
also an interesting shot of at land
looking over as people notices clothes
there's orange armor with green trim and
green gauntlets clearly Aquaman's modern
suit is derived from his ancestor also
in the back
ground of the opposite of the
thoroughfare you can see a structure
forming the exact shape of the Aquaman a
sigil when the recording in mirror
smashes it Mission Impossible style no
one else can know what their exact
mission is then we see more of the
meeting between the two kingdoms the
Atlanteans with their white armor
writing the great white sharks led by
Armand that see crocodile as well as the
kingdom of Zemel riding the sea dragons
they're led by King Marius played by
Dolph Lundgren he's Mira's father
notice what arm says here the Beast is
awakened boos I'm wondering if that
beast refers to that giant crustacean
crab thing that the Brian kingdom has
which we see later in that battle or
maybe some even worse Lovecraftian
horrible sea beast that we haven't seen
yet and in addition to that alliance we
see ORMs other partner black manta 5
super soldiers emerge from this luminous
surface presumably Oram gives this
Atlantean weaponry to black manta to go
after Arthur since Oram can't go on the
land and then we get to the best part of
this footage an extended look at black
mantas attack now some have said that if
you listen closely to the sounds black
manta makes as he lands you can almost
hear robotic filtered voice that kind of
sounds like
[Music]
I don't know of that really what's most
impressive to me is one's camerawork
notice how he features a single unbroken
shot following the foot chase through
the buildings and rooftops of this
seaside town Juan directed a lot of
horror films but he also directed the
movie Furious 7 which is a franchise
known for similar chase sequences and
unbroken takes this also reminds me of
rooftop foot chases and the Jason Bourne
series as well as more recent Bond
movies and moving on in this footage we
see more shots of Oram and Arthur and
gladiator combat Arthur fights off black
mantas guys underwater as well as some
Atlantean soldiers in that sunken ship
but then some badass shots of Atlanta
fighting off some Atlanteans trashley in
that lighthouse so what's going on here
my guess is Lena tried to escape
Atlantis like she wasn't happy with her
life there so she wanted to start a new
life with Thomas on land but the
Atlanteans found out about it and they
consider that child to be a half-breed
abomination so after she's able to fend
them off she leaves them behind in order
to protect them and then she returns to
Atlantis to give a new heir just to
satisfy them but still Arthur is
technically the firstborn we also get a
shot of the monstrous French people
yikes now they have no eyes because they
live in the trench Kingdom and has no
sunlight it's too deep it actually hurts
that Lee intends to try to go down there
and during the millennia that these
kingdoms have been apart the trench
people have evolved their physiology has
changed that they don't need eyes we
also get a shot of what looks like the
Atlantis throne room with Arthur in the
lower right there if you look closely
you can see he's held down in restraints
by Atlantean soldiers also looking at
the other side of this shot that looks
like mera up there on the throne so I
can't tell for sure if that's or more
Nereus it's floating down to them it
looks more like form
so perhaps Arthur is on trial here and
this trial is what leads to a trial by
combat which is why we see Arthur in
orem fighting in that arena and then
after some more fights of this epic
undersea battle between the Atlanteans
and the brine we get to the epoch closer
shot with Aquaman finally in his classic
colors holding at land's trident and
again this look is definitely derived
from at land's ancient garb and kudos to
James Wan for staging this shot with
Arthur simultaneously on land and water
representing the way his character is of
two worlds now here's my question for
you guys if Aquaman goes well hopefully
and is a huge success for Warner
Brothers in DC and I think it definitely
can be you know this footage has
reassured some of the concerns I've had
previously if all this goes well do you
guys think the studio should continue to
go in this direction with more
world-building superheroes like Aquaman
but also like Wonder Woman and Shazam
leading the franchise or would you be
concerned that a successful Aquaman
would still just be a hit in a brand
that is otherwise a little rudderless
and might get overshadowed by other bold
new tonal choices like the Joaquin
Phoenix Joker movie or this
birds-of-prey movie or this new
announced aside squad sequel written and
perhaps directed by James Gunn I guess
my question is would you want Aquaman to
carry the DC brand if all goes well or
do you see it as a potentially good
standalone movie that too just exists in
its own bubble underwater but it really
had a lot of thoughts here and perhaps
I'm putting the cart before the horse so
I'm curious to hear what you guys think
about all this stuff this Aquaman
footage and also what direction you see
the DC Cinematic Universe is going in
general and also this update about James
Gunn joining the DC team so comment down
below with your thoughts and follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at a bus
subscribe to new rockstars for these
in-depth breakdowns of everything you
care about and I'm sorry I left the
shark costume I did in the last Aquaman
video at home I wanted to do in this
video I just forgot but I promise you'll
see it the next time I talk about
Aquaman but you know I kind of like this
little fishy here I'm told that he glows
in the dark you can't really see it here
just new shirts are a good thing also
watches please buy these watches some
things are worth spending money on come
on help this channel please
[Music]